you're watching white coming up on this
week's show what are young people
looking at online Angela finds out how
parents can keep track the drone racing
league championship is coming to London
next year I chapter one of the world's
top pilots and a famous favorite gets an
upgrade in this week's games review
hello welcome to why we're at an event
looking ahead to next season's drone
racing league championship which is
coming to love more from here in a
moment we're going to check in with
Angela house she's been looking into
their secrets
with some worrying finally nearly half
of ten-year-olds say they have the
skills to hide what they're doing online
from their parents that's according to a
recent survey carried out by
london-based security firm and teenagers
are even more savvy to the ways of
hiding things on social media for
example heard of Instagram it stands for
fake Instagram a secondary account set
up on the social platform to keep
content under wraps Instagram is just an
example of the way children want to put
some space between them and their
parents it's not really cool to have
your parents looking over your shoulder
so to speak so I think children like
children of any era want to actually
evade the prying eyes of their parents
and this is just an example of them
doing in the digital age and so they're
laying a sort of trailer false
breadcrumbs for their parents to follow
so they're free to do what they want to
do online however tech-savvy teens and
children may be the dangers are still
not fully understood Douglas and Estelle
Lloyd co-founded an online safety app to
help children learn how to be safe on
the internet they were inspired when one
of their daughters accidentally came
across inappropriate content while
searching for one of her favorite
Nursery Rhymes some parents want or can
invest time to actually edit content and
really look at everything our children
are doing online and guide them and sit
next to them parents are busy so it's
actually it's actually quite difficult
and quite time consuming to to do this
the internet was built for adults it's
not really a safe place for children I
think everybody recognized that so we
wanted to create a place somewhere which
is safe and curated does address that
primary school age group because the
problem you're talking about tends to
take places in our experience once a
child gets there first phone
statistically that's around the 1011 age
so we're addressing that premarket and
giving them those nice lesson skills
ways to behave which hopefully they will
then take on
curated platforms are just one way of
monitoring activity but for all parents
the best thing to preach is caution
whilst overcoming the challenge of
keeping track Angela Barnes Sky News
stay with us still to come I'll be
getting a show in pelle from a
professional drone pilot said to be one
of the world's most talented of coming
right up after a roundup of this week's
tech news Nintendo has denied rumors
that is ending production of its Wii U
console it launched back in November
2012 but sales have since steadily
declined the company has a new console
in the pipeline Nintendo switch due to
go on sale early next year YouTube has
resolved a long-running dispute that
prevented many of its clips being
accessible in Germany the google-owned
video service had been at odds with a
German rights body representing
musicians since 2009 payments will now
be made but neither side has disclosed
the terms a group of 60 students from
Cal Poly University in California are
aiming to build the world's fastest
solar car the vehicle would be powered
by two kilowatts of electricity about
equal to a hair dryer and will propel
two speeds up to and past 65 miles per
hour the team hope it'll be ready to go
by next summer and this palm-sized robot
from san francisco based firm anke has
just launched in the US kosmos
artificial intelligence is based on
feelings programmed into its digital
brain it's also equipped with computer
vision which allows it to recognize who
it's playing with
stick around for our games review we're
on a quest to battle robotics Sky
Pirates and staying
if you haven't heard about the drone
racing it's a bit like football from you
padron the current season has been error
fine or will we stay
toilet we become
the best
earlier on I got to meet one of the
professionals
18 months ago XY fpv that's not your
real name is it it's somebody ruin them
that's my pilot's call sign will talk to
me about the racing that we can sit on
the screen there this is what you do
this is your full-time job isn't it
currently it is yes we raced the DRL
racer to this is it and do all the
pilots who compete have this same drone
yes we all fire the same John same setup
same settings it has four propellers
four motors how fast is it go 60 miles
you know up to a 60mm uses these two
cameras here yes one camera for HD
recording and this one record to the fpv
feed the first person view fit and it
transmits its over the antenna through
this goggle you won't ever try this is
the first person view maybe what you
wear when you're racing yes so you can
see where you're going yes Oh what we're
looking at right now this is the
championship course it's the last race
of the season in Detroit
how do you practice for this for what's
your training regime well I try to put
myself in a new spaces every time so I
learned to adapt to No course that's
very fast so i go to parking garage
abandoned buildings you just find like
difficult areas and try and fly around
the ring photos exactly you might want
to have to try yourself at this roster
have a try at the the war at the thrust
and thrust and exactly I've never flown
a racing drone before this is the thrall
agha so it's noisy we need it has full
control this is the throttle and also
the Y all access oh my quite good I can
see
when you shower this is only for for
showing the power it won't take off
cause it's log see you you're gonna be
traveling around the world doing this
yes exactly what kind of money do you up
well right now it's so so what I
hopefully it will take off and yeah
shatter with rice and any tips anyone
want to get into this kind of racing
learn solarin solder in soldering yes
when you start off doing it yourself you
need to learn to solder also simulator
helps a lot all right thank you I'm
actually gonna take this back you a few
more practice is I go home and maybe you
shouldn't want you I'm the unimpressed
time for this week's games review no
drones I'm afraid but we do have plenty
of adventure here's Holly entitled to
respawn have decided to give their
fast-paced action filled agile
first-person shooter a campaign mode so
while there's still online multiplayer
that the first one was known for its a
lot of fun it's really different as well
first-person shooters can feel a little
bit repetitive sometime it's bit of a
saturated market but the combination of
being able to run around very fast paced
double jump run off walls when you're
not in the mech and then when you get
into your giant robot you're suddenly
this huge powered thing that can fire
bullets back and shoot rockets what
they've managed to do by actually making
it fun to be both in and out of the mech
is very clever and the first person
campaign is very very good it's one of
the most innovative I have played in a
long time so if you are interested in
first-person shooter something a bit
different and you like you know
fast-paced action jumping off walls then
you'll love titanfall 2
trust me after almost a decade in
production d-pad studios our boy is well
worth the wait not only will you be
drawn in by the beautiful art style and
the music the entire thing is just
absolutely gorgeous but it's the
characters the writing the animations
that they have that just draw you in and
a story as well which is something that
I wasn't expecting is really compelling
now the actual gameplay itself is a
combination of platforming puzzle a bit
of twin stick shooter it's incredibly
well polished the art direction itself
is something a studio first he was high
bid so that's very detailed pixel art
and you know you just need to look at
the screens to realize how how lovely it
is but the whole package together is
absolutely wonderful and I think it may
be one of my personal favorite the years
the first I have given their enormously
successful games skyrim a bit of a
facelift and i'm sure a lot of fans will
be very glad to hear that now there are
a couple of really interesting things
that Skyrim special edition now have so
you get all the dlc weather or the
downloadable content you also get access
to player built modifications on the car
if you play on console which before only
pc players could get but that's really
interesting because there is a huge
modding seen as it's called around this
game so that is obviously a huge selling
point the textures and things have been
given a tweak it all looks lovely but it
doesn't lovely when it's static there is
you know the character models and the
animations do sometimes make it look a
little bit dated but when you're walking
around that absolutely gorgeous world
then it's impossible to get lost now I
think if you played on pc and you were
very active with your mod z like making
everything look prettier and really
tweaking it then i'm not sure how much
there will be for you in this new
edition however if you're a console
player and you're interested in modding
or you just want to get lost again in
that world then this is definitely
something to look out for
without their for this mood but if you
enjoyed watching pipe you can watch any
of our episodes on our YouTube playlist
you like staying up to date with all the
latest tech news take a look at the
technology section on the sky news
website will be back next week I hope
you can join us then bye-bye